a día de hoy han pasado casi 15 años
desde que el mundo vio por primera vez
una de las mejores sagas de acción aún
hasta el día de hoy llena de hombres
mamado sangre y groserías que más
podemos pedir por mí pueden comer [ __ ]
y morir
gears of war una de las sagas insignia
de xbox y uno de los juegos más
violentamente divertidos e interesantes
yo en lo personal conozco estos juegos
desde hace muchos años y los he jugado
desde que soy muy pequeño batiendo en
duelos con mis hermanos para ver quién
la varía los platos sucios y dado que es
una de mis sagas de videojuegos
favoritas decide dedicarle un vídeo
recordando el primero de estos juegos y
dándole un vistazo a algunos de sus
secretos o algunos datos que tal vez no
conocías
vamos a ver 30 curiosidades secretos y
detalles de kirk software
el scan podemos llegar a tiempo no vamos
a pasarnos el resto de nuestra vida
huyendo de esta [ __ ]
originalmente el juego fue lanzado el 7
de noviembre de 2006 pero llega a su
masivo éxito el 25 de agosto de 2015
casi nueve años después fue estrenada la
última edición que es una versión
remasterizada del juego original
curiosamente creada por de colisión el
estudio que hoy en día es el encargado
de la serie el imponente general rahm es
un caso curioso ya que el primero su
nombre está basado en el dueño de un
restaurante de comida italiana en donde
los desarrolladores solían comer además
a pesar de ser el antagonista principal
del juego extrañamente fue uno de los
últimos personajes que pensaron siendo
agregado casi al final del desarrollo
del juego es por eso que en el juego
original tiene un diseño muy común como
el de un locus común y corriente sólo
que más grande pero en la última edición
corrigieron este error y crearon un
diseño completamente nuevo para ram
originalmente cliff bleszinski el
creador del juego quería que los
personajes fueran proporciones un poco
más normales si no estuvieran tan
mamados y enormes pero sus compañeros de
trabajo decidieron no hacerle caso ya
que querían que tanto en juego como sus
personajes se distinguirán de otros
juegos del mismo género así creando los
enormes héroes que conocemos hoy en día
uno de los aspectos más importantes de
gears of war fueron sus innovadoras
mecánicas de cobertura que fueron
ideadas por cliff bleszinski mientras
jugaba paintball gracias a adquirir
software la xbox 360 fue mejor y más
potente ya que antes del estreno del
xbox 360 cuando epic games le mostró a
microsoft una versión de prueba del
juego se dieron cuenta de que la memoria
que tenía la consola en ese momento no
era suficiente para que el juego
funcionara correctamente así que
microsoft se vio obligado a duplicar la
memoria del xbox 360 para que tanto el
software como juegos futuros pueden
aprovechar correctamente la potencia de
la nueva consola gastando en el proceso
un billón de dólares como es normal
durante la fase inicial de desarrollo se
descartaron algunos diseños de ciertas
criaturas que no llegaron a la versión
final además también se eliminaron
personajes que inicialmente consideraron
como este dragon locus que eliminaron de
la versión final
de igual manera durante etapas tempranas
de desarrollo se modificó bastante el
diseño original de los personajes
teniendo astas conceptuales de los que
en un principio tenían en mente para
marcos y el escuadrón delta
inicialmente los locos iban a llamar
zeitgeist pero desecharon la idea ya que
nintendo ya había sacado un juego con
ese mismo nombre y querían evitar
cualquier problema por derechos de autor
albert einstein y su banda megadeth les
gustó tanto el juego que decidió crear
una canción con el nombre y el software
para que lo incluyeran en el título
uno de los rasgos físicos más notorios y
característicos de marcus es la cicatriz
que tiene en el rostro esta cicatriz en
los reveló luego en una de las novelas
del juego la obtuvo durante sus años de
prisión cuando un guardia de seguridad
le tendió una trampa y lo encerró con
dos perros en una celda
marcus logró acabar con ellos pero sin
embargo los perros también lograron
hacerle daño a marcus creando su
característica cicatriz el juego
inicialmente iba a ser en primera
persona pero cuando su creador vio lo
bien que se veía el juego gráficamente
pensó que sería una lástima que los
jugadores no pudieran ver a su personaje
así que tomando inspiración de la cámara
sobre el hombro de fez y 24 decidieron
continuar en tercera persona
en el año 2007 el estudio new line
cinema adquirió los derechos para una
adaptación cinematográfica de khyber
software tengo planes para hacer una
película basada en los videojuegos pero
desde entonces dichos planes para crear
la película se han visto estancados y
aún a día de hoy nadie sabe si algún día
veremos que esta película aún así el
actor de bautista en varias ocasiones ha
declarado que le encantaría interpretar
marcus y ha estado haciendo todo lo
posible para lograrlo lo cual
francamente sería genial pero de momento
nada ha sido confirmado así que david
tendrá que conformarse por ahora siendo
un personaje invitado en el multijugador
de khyber 5 el mapa write low es el
padre del multijugador de gears of war
ya que fue el primer mapa en ser
completado en su totalidad y fue en este
mismo mapa en donde probaron muchos
aspectos del juego es por eso que este
es el único mapa que está presente en
los tres juegos originales
es indiscutible que este juego tiene uno
de los mejores doblajes al latino y una
gran selección de voces en su versión
original y curiosamente las voces que le
han dado vida a marcus tanto en su
versión en inglés como en latino son
bastante populares ya que por una parte
en su versión en inglés quien da guasa
marcus es jon dimaggio quien es conocido
por también ser la voz en inglés de
vender y de cheque el perro por otra
parte en latino su voz fue prestada por
el gran sebastián la pur que ya le había
dado su voz a personajes como darth
vader diego coloso y muchos más
así que si marcus ha tenido voz es
bastante famosas
en una etapa temprana del desarrollo
dominique link fue el nombre que habían
pensado para dos pero decidieron
cambiarlo contra el desarrollador rom
ferguson vio encima del escritorio de
cliff bleszinski una caja de cigarrillos
con el nombre santiago lo que le daría
la inspiración para el nombre de tom
a pesar de que en el juego no se
menciona explícitamente los locos en
realidad son humanos multados por la
emulsión durante décadas que se
establecieron en colonias bajo tierra
mutando cada vez más con los años hasta
convertirse en los locos que invadieron
cera
a lo largo de todo el juego podemos ver
bastantes cajas de cereal con el nombre
kirsch crunch
estos son los diseños conceptuales de
algunas armas que fueron eliminadas del
juego
al lanzar el arma insignia de la saga
fuera del creador del juego cliff
bleszinski que tenía en mente desde
muchos años antes de crear escribir
software y está inspirada las bayonetas
usadas desde el siglo 17 además algo
interesante es que en el inicio del
desarrollo se tuvo la idea de que los
locos tuvieran un arma equivalente a la
lanza
originalmente los locos tendrían una
hummer boost personalizada que tendría
un taladro en el extremo lamentablemente
esta idea fue desechada
el día en el que los locos emergieron
hacia la superficie y la guerra comenzó
fue conocido como el día e iu a pesar de
que mi red considera la reina de los
locos ella no fue quien lideró el ataque
a la humanidad en un inicio quien estuvo
a cargo del ataque a la superficie del
día e fue nada más que con el enemigo
principal de gears of war 2 judgment
según el loro de la saga la invasión
locus fue tan inesperada y tan brutal
que acabó con más de 70% de la humanidad
originalmente verde iba a ser el
deportista rudo y gracioso y que iba a
ser el científico sabelotodo pero luego
de conocer el actor de voz que le haría
vida a cold y darse cuenta de que el
tipo era muy carismático y divertido
decidieron invertir los roles de
colinvers modificando los personajes
para que sus personalidades fueran más
acordes dejándolos como todos los
conocemos
el antagonista principal y el jefe final
del juego es el general run pero en un
concepto inicial el gesto final del
juego iba a ser la hidra o el v river
que vemos en gears of war 2 y en yours
tactics pero los desarrolladores
decidieron cambiarlo ya que no tuvieron
el tiempo para diseñar la secuencia
final con esta criatura así que dejaron
la batalla con ram en su lugar
a pesar de parecer muy obvio el juego no
toma lugar en el planeta tierra y el
software se sitúa en un planeta ficticio
llamado cera este nombre fue pensado por
el planeta para demostrar la brutalidad
y la crueldad de las guerras que se han
librado aquí pues para nombrarlo usaron
el nombre ares y lo escribieron al revés
ares es el dios de la guerra y la
personificación de la matanza y la
crueldad así que pensaron que el nombre
sería perfecto para este planeta
gears of war ex side fue un título
cancelado en el universo de givers
estibas en un juego para xbox 360 como
el shooter sobre raíles que saldría para
kinect se tenía planeado que este juego
fue una precuela de el primer software
en abril de 2012 se anunció oficialmente
que el juego fue cancelado por motivos
desconocidos al inicio del desarrollo se
pensó en incluir en el juego un medidor
moral que lo que haría es que si tus
compañeros están deprimidos o llevan
mucho tiempo bajo combate podrían llegar
a suicidarse esta idea fue descartada
pues en primer lugar sería algo que
interrumpiría la acción y en segundo
lugar pensaron que sería algo injusto
que en medio de una lucha perdidas
compañeros por algo que no puedes
controlar
a pesar de que los brumas tienen una
apariencia muy parecida a la de un
reptil o un dinosaurio estas criaturas
fueron creadas por los locos a partir de
simios que alteraron genéticamente
el planeta cera tiene un antecedente muy
triste de guerra sin parar pues antes de
la invasión locus la cob y laurie
llevaban 80 años seguidos en guerra por
el control de los recursos restantes del
planeta y por el control de la emulsión
una sustancia que serviría como una
fuente de energía esta guerra fue
conocida como las guerras del péndulo
después de que la cob ganará la guerra
la paz duró únicamente seis semanas pues
luego de un mes y medio de que las
guerras del péndulo acabaran y sin que
aún la humanidad se hubiera recuperado
los locos atacaron iniciando la guerra
entre humanos y locus que duraría 17
años lo que quiere decir que el planeta
será lleva casi 100 años en un ambiente
de guerras constantes al comienzo del
desarrollo del juego se tenía planeado
que los jugadores pudieran elegir el
género de nuestro hermano en armas 2
pudiendo elegir entre el doble que todos
conocemos una versión femenina llamado
mini esto fue descartado porque querían
evitarse la molestia de tener que grabar
dos versiones de cada diálogo que
tuviera todo antes de que el juego fuera
terminado muchas personas de microsoft e
incluso algunos del personal del equipo
de desarrollo querían eliminar la
violencia del juego ya que pensaban que
era demasiado violento y contenía
demasiada sangre
así que trataron de suavizar el juego e
incluso eliminar conceptos como la
icónica lancer afortunadamente muchas de
las personas que desarrollaron el juego
incluido su creador se arriesgaron y
dejaron el juego tal y como ellos
querían lo cual evidentemente fue la
decisión correcta ya que incluso el
mismo bill gates luego le diría a cliff
bleszinski que el juego y todas sus
características le encantaron salvando
así al violento y desencarnado juego que
todos conocemos y amamos
he aquí las 30 curiosidades de uno de
los juegos más violentos pero más
divertidos y únicos desde los últimos
tiempos como dije antes me encanta esta
saga desde años que juego que ir
software y no podía esperar para
dedicarle un vídeo ahora estoy esperando
alguna noticia sobre gears of wars 6 y
el futuro de este universo pero dime qué
te parecieron todos estos datos ya
conocidas alguno si quieres que le
dedique algún vídeo de curiosidades
algún videojuego que tengas en mente
déjamelo saber los comentarios o en
twitter hasta la próxima
[Música]